[Music]
all right what's up fellow Geeks today
we have the Avatar frontiers of pendora
collector edition here this thing is
it's pretty big so I'm actually standing
up to unbox this so let's just go ahead
and do this uh on the side say really
nothing much it's just a all graphics
and I really have no idea what to expect
with this thing so with that let's just
get into it so let's open up the top
real quick and the first thing you'll
see is the main game so let's just cut
this open real quick with our knife
really
quickly just like that because a lot of
you like to see what's inside so let's
see what's inside okay first thing in
the box so so let's go and open this up
so you get the main game and also you
have a collector edition digital content
so CH to Works pack ultimate pack
digital artbook and season pass so that
comes together with this thing so that's
out of the way main game out of the way
let's move on and let me just put this
down so you guys can see what's going on
so this is the cardboard cutout that
holds the main game and then with this
and let's just slowly open this up and
ooh some things have falling out already
the first thing is a resources
development Administration notebook and
let's see oh uh there's a name here
priia chin and let's just skip through
oh okay so this is the stuff she
sketched in a free time in this notebook
it's kind of similar to what they did
with h journal in the Halo Reach
collectors edition so that's nice got
little indicators here and there the
this on means death obviously looks like
some kind of speed boost where to find
out in game and the rest is blank for
you to fill up with your own stuff so
that's a nice touch here the art of
Avatar frontiers of Pandora this thing
is in pretty tight and there's a lot
more stuff going on in the back I don't
want to spoil too much for you guys but
this is what you're going to get so with
that let us close this and yeah get a
pretty nifty artbook here and this how
the bag looks like and this is how it
looks like when it's opened up very
pretty outb we have down here all right
let's move on to the next bit which is
this thing over here
let's open it up it's an envelope and
ooh so we have these postcard like
things on here Rog graphs if I'm not
wrong that's what they're called and
let's check the back okay so they're not
postcards but they do have little
symbols at the back here like this and
this so there's a lot to find out and I
honestly again need to play the game to
figure out what all these means so let's
put this aside next up we have a number
certific for the collector edition with
the protagonist on the front and pretty
hard cardboard uh we are number
1,651 so that's Nifty let's go on to the
next thing we have a stealable case all
right pretty sick stuff and when we open
it up okay so they just kind of reflect
each other so with this over here she's
over here and with her over here this is
over here pretty nifty steelb case uh
nice one for the collectionist let's go
to this thing which looks like a folder
of sorts and oh we'll get to that in a
bit
oh oh so what we have here is the
blueprint for the EMP pyro that you saw
on the cover and of course you meet in
game and it's pretty nice it shows off
what exactly the MP pyro has been
equipped with and how tall it is and
everything compared to a normal human
being so that's this is a pretty nice
touch it's not very thin it's nice thick
paper so they're not really skimping off
with quality down here really nice kind
of want to actually just frame this up
all right let's just put this back
inside the folder this is what's inside
it is an amp pyro being shot with an
arrow by the protagonist and look at
that there there are a couple parts here
so we have one two the whole figure
three four five so let's actually just
open this up all
right o oh so it comes out like
this oh okay hold on it is stored inside
the styrofoam box let us cut this
open
again ah all right before we continue
the unboxing this channel is supported
by brand to help us improve our content
and keep us going so stick around for
this sponsored message here at geek
culture we've tested plenty of chairs
but Secret Life gaming chairs remain one
of our favorites whether it's for work
or play they feel great to lean back
against with the ergonomic features
offering support for the whole body from
the head and back to the arms and even
something for your butt this mix of
fourman function helps the Titan Evo
2022 deliver the best seating experience
like no other for more information check
out secretlab.co yeah this thing has got
some weight to it damn okay all right
let's just remove everything some of the
smaller pieces have been taped down so
be mindful of
that first things first is our
protagonist I have no idea what her name
is but one thing that I know for sure is
that she's a real badass look at her
na'vi B it's long as heck this thing
isn't shop of course and on her back is
an assault rifle that that she uses in
game and yeah she looks really good and
this stump will be inser into the Pyro
later on so that's that we also have a
tail right here so we might as well just
insert that in real quick so we're going
to do that like this and just going to
put it right
here right let's get all the way in
there okay my bad that is a tight fit
okay sick so she looks like this and
here are two back ends of the arrow that
she slots into the EMP Pyro
here we go Arrow number one and arrow
number
two just like that and next up before we
get into the bigger piece is the EMP
pyro arm apparently this thing is
magnetic so we'll see how that works out
later on pretty nice detailing here a
lot nice weathering you can see you know
it's really it's really F the base
essentially is the EMP pyro look at look
at that it's just a tall PA though so
according to the instructions the hand
goes to the bottom over here right here
so just apparently it's magnetic oh it
is magnetic I can feel that all right so
with the hand there is a slot right here
and there is another slot right here
that's meant to be pushed into the Rock
so we just going to find those
spots all right this is a at the bottom
here where the finger is at and B all
right and it's supposed to stay just
like this
all right so now we're going to be
taking the smaller of the two Arrow
backs and we're going to be sloting this
in to the side like this like that and
now this longer piece goes to the front
push it
in just like
that all right so this is how the piece
will look like so far and now we're
going to be putting our protagonist in
with health figure this stump is
supposed to go in right here at the top
and this is the complete figure I've got
to say this is one of the better looking
CES that we've seen this year I think
this can rival the aled call C that you
can check out like right here this thing
looks magnificent with a lot of
weathering a lot of good details and I
think scaling wise our na'vi protagonist
over here is really nicely scaled to the
EMP pyro right here especially after
looking at the AC Mirage collectible
this is actually wonderful this is
packed with so much detail all around
the figure even at the back here look at
that weathering on the mech and just the
arrows and oh my gosh look at her figure
it's crazy her hands where she has
little bendas of like of canvas wrapped
all around her her Tech vest her Tech
belt everything is on a lot of love and
care has been put into the C figure and
yeah I think again I think this one of
the best ones we've seen this year all
right that's all we have for the Avatar
frontiers of Pandora collector edition
there is a lot going on down here we've
got the numbered certificate we've got
the art book we've got the steelbook
case we've got the main game we've got
three images that you see here we've got
the notebook we've got the blueprint for
the Empire and of course the Magnificent
collector edition statue of the
protagonist on top of a EMP pyro so this
looks amazing there is a lot of value
down here at least in my opinion but let
me know what you guys think let me know
if you guys are getting one CE for
yourselves and if you'll be exploring
Pandora like the rest of us will be very
soon once we get that se into our PS5
thank you for watching the video if you
enjoy what we do make sure to follow us
on all our socials right here to keep up
to date with everything that we put out
daily and make sure you hit that like
And subscribe buttons it goes a long way
in helping out the channel in any case
this is Zen have a great week and I'll
catch youall
soon